the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi I'm dr. buck danfa adesh I'm a
research associate at MIT doing
researchers professor John a segment I
loved biochemistry and I'm going to help
you solve some problems today let's work
together through question five or
problem set five this is an excellent
question about sugar biochemistry
specifically we're gonna find out how
man owes an isomer of glucose gets to
enter metabolism by being converted into
fructose 6-phosphate
now Manos is a common sugar that's found
in polysaccharides and glycoproteins
here is the transformation that converts
Manos shown here to mannose-6-phosphate
in first step and then in a second step
to fructose 6-phosphate our goal here
will be to figure out the mechanism for
this two transformations let's take a
look at the first transformation we're
converting Manos to mannose-6-phosphate
now as you guys have encountered in
biochemistry adding a phosphate group is
a ubiquitous transformation and it's
catalyzed by proteins called kinases now
kinase is typically used ATP the energy
currency of the cell as a phosphate
donor and transfer the furthest most
phosphates are called gamma phosphate
onto the substrate and leaving behind
adp a similar transformation will be
happening here in part one of the
problem we're mannose is going to be
converted to mannose-6-phosphate by an
by a kinase and the source of the
phosphate is going to be ATP which in
the process will yield adp now in order
for the kinase to to work to react with
ATP we also need magnesium so a salt of
magnesium with ATP is actually essential
for this reaction to work now let's take
a look at the structure of ATP to gain a
little bit more mechanistic insight as
you know ATP or adenosine triphosphate
has these three phosphate groups
attached to a five carbon sugar called
ribose and a base adenine which we're
not going to draw out here now the
phosphates in ATP are typically labeled
alpha the one closest to the sugar beta
and gamma now in order for ATP to react
notice these four
negative charges on the phosphates they
need to be neutralized in order for the
molecule to become reactive so this is
what magnesium is doing so at least
early on in the reaction magnesium is
going to neutralize two of these four
negative charges while the other two
negative charges will be neutralized by
positively charged amino acids in the
active site of the kinase once all the
charges are neutralized
then the phosphorus that the Gama
position will become available to be
attacked by a nucleophile in our case
the the six hydroxyl of manos so
therefore the reaction proceeds as
follows a base in the active site will
activate our hydroxyl which then can
attack the Gama position of the
phosphate and then the phosphate is
transferred to the mannose and it's
going to leave behind adp now notice
during this reaction magnesium which was
coordinating two of these negative
charges will probably move to coordinate
these two charges or the newly formed
charge here in ADP and that would also
help stabilize the ADP into the active
site of the kinase this mechanistic
insight basically answers part one of
the problem to talk about part two of
the problem we need to remember
something fundamental about sugars
biochemistry namely that five and six
carbon sugars exists in equilibrium
between a linear form and cyclic forms
now sugars that you've encountered
already like glucose and fructose they
are in equilibrium between linear and
cyclic forms so let's take a look at
them first this is glucose as you know
it's an aldehyde that has hydroxyl group
on all the other carbons in this
stereochemistry now this is the linear
form of glucose and as an aldehyde it
can react with good nucleophiles like
these hydroxyls to form cyclic hemi
it tells if the reaction occurs was a
hydroxyl position for when we're gonna
close a five membered ring hemiacetal
which is shown here these kind of
structures are called fewer noses so
this is the gluco furanose now if
instead we react with the five carbon
then we're going to close a six membered
ring which is called a pure knows this
is glucopyranose
now while sugars are in equilibrium
between the linear and the cyclic forms
the cyclic forms tend to be predominant
so in equilibrium will be primarily 99%
a cyclic form and only about 1% linear
form nevertheless the presence of the
linear form allows the sugars to undergo
some interesting transformations one of
which we're exploring in this question
similarly here is fructose now fructose
has the carbonyl at the two position
it's a keto group and then hydroxyl
groups on all the other carbons and just
like glucose it can form cyclic
hemiacetals
so if the reaction happens between the
carbonyl and the hydroxyl at position 5
it's going to close a five-member ring
shown here this is - a furanose this
will be fructose furanose if the
reaction happens with the hydroxyl at
the position six then we're going to be
closing a six-member ring shown here
this is fructose pyrrha knows once again
just like for glucose the equilibrium
it's strongly shifted towards the cyclic
forms nevertheless there is enough of
the linear form to allow certain kind of
chemistry to happen now going back to
solving part two of our problem that is
converting from mannose 6-phosphate
which is a sugar with a sigma six member
ring cyclic structure to fructose 6
phosphate sugar with a five-member ring
cyclic structure keeping
mine would just disgusted sugars there
they're in equilibrium between the
cyclic structures and their linear
structures linear forms one good place
to start to figure out how this
transformation will happen is to write
the linear forms of the two molecules
here now for the mannose 6-phosphate we
notice we have a hemiacetal
functionality a carbon one which is
attached to both a hydroxyl group and
another oxygen so this carbon will form
an aldehyde in the linear form so let's
write the linear form of mannose
6-phosphate
alright so notice at carbon 1 we're
going to have an aldehyde and then all
the other carbons we have a six carbon
chain right now in terms of mechanism
this is just a reverse of the hemiacetal
formation and it's going to require a
base to deprotonate the hydroxyl here at
carbon one and then we're going to need
to reap relate at the hydroxyl in
position five to form this hydroxyl here
now something to keep in mind though the
way this enzyme works is we don't really
know if the enzyme is catalyzing this
transformation is written here or the
enzyme is just binding the linear form
that will be in equilibrium in solution
of mannose 6-phosphate
similarly for fructose 6-phosphate
we can write its linear form notice
fructose 6-phosphate has a carbon - it's
a hemiketal functionality this carbon is
attached to both a hydroxyl and an
oxygen so that will open up to form a
ketone
all right this is our fructose
6-phosphate in a linear form and there
is a two position we have the ketone now
it would be a good idea at this point to
number the carbons to see what do we
need to do on going from this linear
form of mannose-6-phosphate to this
linear form of fructose 6-phosphate
so here we have carbon 6 5 4 3 2 1 and
we have carbons 6 5 4 3 2 1
alright and if we contrast the two
structures we notice the carbons from 3
to 6 in both cases are in fact the same
and we even have the hydroxyls in the
right stereochemical orientation in the
right stereochemistry and all we need to
do is move the carbonyl group from that
one position here in mannose-6-phosphate
to the two position in the fructose
6-phosphate so this transformation can
be accomplished by an intermediate which
you have seen already in glycolysis the
intermediate that allows to go from
glucose 6-phosphate to fructose
6-phosphate
which is an sis in dial so it's
essentially inhalation with the carbon
with a hydrogen on carbon 2 so if we
wanted to form the enol here which as
you know from the carbonyl video so a
base could deprotonate and allow the
electrons to move to form another
hydroxyl on the one position because
this is a C's sis in dial to the two
hydroxyl are going to end up on the same
side of the double bond
once again let's number our carbons 4 3
2 1 and this is our sis in dye all right
so we have 2 hydroxyls they're both
attached to a double bond and sis means
they're both on the same side of the
molecule and this allows the enzyme to
basically switch back and forth between
which one of these hydroxyl becomes the
carbonyl if we go backwards we have the
carbon yellow that one position however
if we if we go forward we can move the
carbonyl on the 2 position so that's
just the reverse of the inhalation
reaction in which we will deeper Nate
this hydroxyl and repr Nate at carbon-12
take us forward to generate 2 keto group
which is fructose 6-phosphate in the
linear form now from here in the very
last step we just need to close the ring
so that's just a hemiketal formation we
have a base deprotonated hydroxyl
position 5 and this will attack the
ketone to form the hemiketal group that
we see in fructose 6-phosphate so now
this is basically the the curved arrow
mechanism from going from mannose
6-phosphate to fructose 6-phosphate now
some key points to notice here is that
this inhalation reaction where the base
removes this alpha hydrogen would not
have been possible in the cyclic
structures if you look here that this
hydrogen the pKa is about 30 now once we
form the the linear structure here the
pKa of this hydrogen now it's about 18
so that's like 12 orders of magnitude
more acidic and that allows the reaction
to form this scene dial which allows the
formation of the fructose-6-phosphate so
its take-home message here is that
opening and closing the Ring of the
sugars allows a lot of interesting
chemistry to happen
part three of this question asked us to
comment on why when going from Manos to
fructose we have to go through the
mannose 6-phosphate intermediate now
this turns out to be a very common motif
in carbohydrate chemistry because adding
a phosphate group is a way of regulation
of which product is being formed taking
a closer look at at our transformation
we see that if we didn't have the
phosphate group at the sixth position
this hydroxyl would be available and
could potentially be involved in forming
cyclic forms as we recall our discussion
on fructose whenever we have a six
hydroxyl available the fructose can form
the fructose paranhos form in addition
to the fructose furanose form so by
blocking this position with a phosphate
we're limiting the reaction to produce
only one product naming the fructose
furanose additionally adding a phosphate
group to a sugar imparts it negative
charge and that allows the sugar to be
trapped inside the cell and allows
metabolism to occur much more
efficiently this is something that
you've already encountered in glycolysis
where glucose in the first step is first
converted to glucose 6-phosphate